Prime Day has come and gone, and there's more
of July behind us than in front of us.
It's time to take a look at the new offerings
you should keep your eyes open for on Amazon
Prime Video in August 2019.
Amazon Prime's new original series Carnival
Row mixes fantasy, mystery, and a politically
tense environment that, for some people at
least, feels all too familiar at this point.
Starring Orlando Bloom as human Rycroft Philostrate
and Cara Delevingne as as the winged faerie
Vignette Stonemoss, Carnival Row is set in
a Victorian-era city where the kinds of fantasy
creatures we're not used to seeing outside
of The Lord of the Rings or a Dungeons & Dragons
campaign are an everyday fact of life.
Kind of like that Bright movie, but maybe…
y'know.
Better.
"Fairy lives don't matter today."
But while these creatures' existences are
accepted, that doesn't mean the humans of
this fictional world like them very much.
The fantasy creatures of Carnival Row - like
Vignette - are refugees from a war-torn land,
and are subjected to inhumane laws while living
in the city.
One freedom denied them is romance with humans,
making the affair between Rycroft and Vignette
a risky one.
While the pair wrestle with that looming danger,
they must also investigate a string of unsolved
murders.
All eight hourlong episodes of Carnival Row
will be released on Amazon Prime on August
30.
With a premise so unique and promising, it
definitely looks to be worth checking out.
If the trailer for next year's Top Gun: Maverick
got your blood pumping, but you don't want
to wait until 2020 to see Tom Cruise in action,
Amazon Prime might have a partial solution
for you.
On August 23, 2018's critically-lauded Mission:
Impossible - Fallout lands on the service,
featuring starring turns from Cruise, Henry
Cavill, and Ving Rhames.
Cavill's career owes a lot to Zack Snyder,
who directed the actor as comic book icon
Superman in Man of Steel, Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice, and Justice League.
And Amazon Prime might be a favorite place
for Zack Snyder fans in August.
Snyder's Persian War epic 300 will be Prime's
very first new August arrival, with his original
story Sucker Punch arriving later in the month.
While none of Snyder's superhero flicks will
arrive on Prime in August, Guillermo del Toro's
Hellboy II: The Golden Army will be there,
and it will be joined by other monster-filled
action flicks like 2014's Godzilla and the
Aaron Eckhart-led graphic novel adaptation
I, Frankenstein.
The process of buying a home isn't known for
its lack of stress.
But if you find yourself looking for a new
place to hang your hat and find the whole
thing impossibly frustrating, maybe drop by
Amazon Prime at the end of August for 1986's
horror sequel Poltergeist II: The Other Side.
Starring Craig T. Nelson, JoBeth Williams,
and Heather O'Rourke, Poltergeist II is the
second entry in the saga of the Freeling family
- people who just can't get a break when it
comes to where they plant their stakes.
Though they've moved from the home where vengeful
spirits plagued them in 1982's Poltergeist,
the family soon learns the truth of the old
adage, "No matter where you go… there the
creepy ghosts from the first movie are."
"They're back…"
But if supernatural fears aren't your cup
of tea, Amazon is also offering some scares
based more firmly in the real world with 2013's
Manuscripts Don't Burn.
Made by Iranian filmmaker Mohammad Rasoulof,
the thriller follows a writer named Kasra
as he attempts to escape Iran with his politically-charged
writing after the country's authorities learn
of his plans.
In 1996, former US Director of Central Intelligence
William Colby disappeared under mysterious
circumstances.
Fifteen years later, a documentary was released
called The Man Nobody Knew: In Search of My
Father, CIA Spymaster William Colby, directed
and narrated by the late Colby's son Carl.
Driven by a son's need to know the truth about
his father and inevitably tied to some of
the most important historical events of the
20th century, The Man Nobody Knew succeeds
as what Philadelphia Inquirer's Steven Rea
calls, quote, "a deeply personal film and
an important historical document."
The documentary arrives on Amazon Prime on
August 31.
If you'd prefer something with a bit more
distance from the present day, 1983's western
drama Sacred Ground premieres the same day.
The film is noteworthy both a rare western
produced in the 1980s, well after the popularity
of the genre had faded.
It's also the final film of character actor
Tim McIntire, a recognizable "oh, it's that
guy" of the 60s and 70s.
Set the same year the American Civil War began,
Sacred Ground revolves around the ostracism
that a white man and Native American woman
face when they choose to live as man and wife.
If you need some more laughter in your life,
Amazon Prime is serving up some uniquely humorous
offerings in August.
The indy comedy Computer Chess shows up on
Prime at the end of the month, and if you
haven't seen it, it's well worth a look - 2013's
critics couldn't get enough of it.
Filmed completely on analog video and, as
The AV Club's Mike D'Angelo put it, having
the look of an industrial training film from
the '80s, Computer Chess unfolds over a weekend
summit of computer chess programmers - the
kind of smart tech people who helped create
the world we live in now.
If you find yourself enjoying that style of
quirky, nerdy humor, keep things going by
following an atomic scientist to a town full
of people-eating salesmen in 1999's comedy-horror
Top of the Food Chain.
"Some kind of monster."
"What the heck are you guys shooting at?"
But if you don't want to spend a weekend simply
nerding out, you can instead spend some time
with Anna Kendrick and Blake Lively in the
twisted black comedy mystery movie A Simple
Favor.
"What were you saying about me being a f---ing
psycho?"
Or, for something a little sweeter and more
family-friendly, watch as Michael Keaton dies
and comes back to life as a snowman in 1998's
Jack Frost.
"Hey Charlie.
Thanks for giving me a second chance to be
your dad."
Staying in with that high-concept movie won't
just give you a weird blast of nostalgia;
it can also help take your mind off just how
hot it is outside.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.